عملت الشيف آنا ماريا هيريراس لمدة 25 عامًا في
بعض أرقى المطابخ في العالم ،
لكنها أدارت ظهرها
لأضواء الطهي الساطعة لهذه
مرحبًا ، فأنت جاهز لتناول بعض
الحلوى في مطبخ المدرسة في دبي فيينا واستمتع
بغدائك والعملاء الأصغر سنًا.
أنت جيد ،
إنه جيد حقًا ، أحب سماع ما
يقولونه عن الطعام وهم
يتحدثون معي بالفعل عن
الطعام ، إنه شعور ممتع للغاية أن
آنا جزء من مخطط مبتكر
لا يتعلم فيه أطفال المدارس فقط
يتم إعداد وجبات الغداء من
المنتجات الطازجة التي يزرعها الأطفال في هذا
الدفيئة المبنية لهذا الغرض ،
إنه درس عملي في
الفوائد البيئية للأغذية من مصادر محلية ، حيث
تقوم المدرسة بإعادة تدوير النفايات وترصد عن كثب
استهلاكها للطاقة ،
هل تعرف شيئًا يسمى spf
هذه  تُستخدم biodomes كصفوف دراسية ، وهو
مكان مثالي لدراسة علم الأحياء والكيمياء ،
ويسمى هذا العامل ووفقًا
لمبدأ المدرسة
إنهم مثاليون لمواضيع أخرى
مثل التاريخ
، فقد يكون الأمر أننا ننظر إلى
نباتات قصب السكر ونفهم كيف
أثر ذلك على التجارة عبر منطقة
البحر الكاريبي أو تجارة الرقيق
ومزارع السكر ، حيث يتم
إدخال أهمية
البيئة في حياة  الشباب
هنا
خلفية غير مألوفة في مدينة مثل
دبي محاطة
بالصحراء وفي بلد يتم فيه استيراد حوالي 90 من
المواد الغذائية
، وبالنسبة لآنا فقد جلبت معنى أكبر
بكثير مما وجدته في حياتها
المهنية السابقة ،
فتحت الباب ولدي  حديقة أعشاب في
الخارج
وكان الأطفال هم من
زرعوها ، لذا
عيشوا هذه التجربة وفعلوا بالفعل
ما أؤمن به وأطعم
هؤلاء الناس
ما أعتقد حقًا أنه يجب أن يخرج
من مطبخي
هو كل
ما تنوي المدرسة في النهاية  لتصبح
محايدة تمامًا للكربون
، ولدى آنا خطط لجلب المزرعة لتقسيم
وجبات الغداء إلى مؤسسات أخرى حول
العالم ،
لكنهم اليوم يزرعون بالفعل
جذور الجيل الجديد الواعي بالبيئة